ELECTIONS CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS TO ORDER.
AND ASK THAT THE MEMBERS APPEAR.
THE TIME OF NINE THIRTY HAVE AN
OCCURRED -- WE'RE READY TO ROLL
WE GOT.
GOT SOME AUTHORS SIR WE WILL
HAVE SOME AUTHORS.
WE JUST NEED SOME MEMBERS.
BOB FOR FOLKS THAT ARE HERE ON
AB TWO OH ONE OF THAT MEASURE AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR HAS
BEEN PULLED AND WILL BE HEARD AS
SUBS WHEN HEARING
.
SENATOR NIELSEN IS HERE SO WE
CAN COMMENCE AS A SUB COMMITTEE --
IF WE AN AUTHOR [inaudible]
SO ASSEMBLY.
MEMBER BERMAN OR BONTA
[inaudible]
OR ASSEMBLY WOMAN IRWIN OR
STRIKE THAT -- ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW.
WE WOULD WELCOME YOUR ATTENDANCE
[inaudible]
YEAH
SO -- THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA -- AB.
EIGHT FORTY NINE AND WE HAVE A
SUBCOMMITTEE SO.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB EIGHT
FORTY NINE TODAY.
REDISTRICTING IS OF CRUCIAL
IMPORTANCE TO LOCAL DEMOCRACY
HOW CITY OR COUNTY ELECTION.
DISTRICTS ARE DRAWN CAN HELP
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT I
COMMUNITY WILL BE FAIRLY
REPRESENTED BY THE MOST INTIMATE
AND PROXIMATE GOVERNMENT.
BODIES UNLIKE STATE LEVEL
REDISTRICTING THERE ARE VERY FEW
REQUIREMENTS GOVERNING CITY AND
COUNTY REDISTRICTING TO ENSURE
THE PROCESS IS FAIR.
AND TRANSPARENT.
AND THAT THE PUBLIC AND
ESPECIALLY UNDER REPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES ARE ENGAGED IN THE
PROCESS.
AB EIGHT FORTY NINE WILL BRING
TRANSPARENCY.
AND CREATE CLEAR STANDARDS FOR
CITIES AND COUNTIES BY EXPANDING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. FOR NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
OTHERWISE ALL TOO OFTEN.
OVERLOOKED THIS BILL ENSURES
THAT REDISTRICTING MAPS ARE MADE
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC BEFORE
THEY CAN BE ADOPTED.
AND ALONG WITH OTHER
TRANSPARENCY MEASURES SETS A
MINIMUM OF FOUR PUBLIC HEARINGS
TO ALLOW. FOR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION I HAVE AND WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE CITIES
AND COUNTIES TO ENSURE THAT WE
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN
COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT AND
TRANSPARENCY.
I THINK WE ARE CLOSE TO A
RESOLUTION THAT WILL ADDRESS
SOME OF THEIR CONCERNS RELATING
TO THE BIRD IN ASSOCIATED WITH
THE REQUIREMENTS OF NOTICE IN
TRANSLATION.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
ASSOCIATIONS FOR THEIR
ENGAGEMENT WITH MY OFFICE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITH ME HERE TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHT FORTY NINE
R. NICHOLAS HI TORN.
I WITH COMMON CAUSE CALIFORNIA
AND SOPHIA GARCIA DELORES WORKED
A FOUNDATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TERM.
OXEN SUPPORT GO AHEAD THANK YOU
TERM BERGEN MEMBERS NICKEL SIDE
ON REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
COMMON CAUSE.
WE'RE STRONG SUPPORTERS OF AB
EIGHT FOUR NINE WHICH PROVIDES A
CRUCIAL SAFETY NET.
AGAINST GERRYMANDERING AND CITY
AND COUNTY REDUCING.
REDISTRICTING IS ABSOLUTELY
CRUCIAL AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT TO ENSURE
REPRESENTATIVE AS WELL AS
INCLUSIVE DEMOCRACY.
UNFORTUNATELY SOMETIMES THE
LOCAL REDUCING PROCESS ABUSED
AND WAY THAT UNDERMINES
REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT MOST
SIGNIFICANTLY BY CRACKING
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES RURAL
COMMUNITIES WORKING CLASS
COMMUNITIES OR MINORITY
COMMUNITIES.
THE WAY THAT DILUTES THE POWER
OTHER VOTE AND UNDERMINES LOCAL
POLITICAL ACCOUNTABILITY.
THIS IS IN SIGNIFICANT PART
BECAUSE UNLIKE WITH STATE AND
CONGRESSIONAL REDISTRICTING
THEY'RE ALMOST NO MANDATORY
STANDARDS GOD LOCAL REDUCING TO
PREVENT SUCH ABUSE AND TO ENSURE
DIVERSE PARTICIPATION IN THE
PROCESS. FOR EXAMPLE UNLIKE
STATE AND CONGRESSIONAL REDUCING
THERE IS NO REQUIREMENT FOR
LOCAL REDUCING THE COMMUNITIES
AND NEIGHBORHOODS BE KEPT HOLE.
IN FACT OTHER THAN EQUAL
POPULATION AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THE FEDERAL VOTING RIGHTS ACT
WHICH ARE FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS
THERE NO MANDATORY CRITERIA AT
ALL FOR LOCAL REGISTERING JUST
DISCRETIONARY CONSIDERATIONS.
THE CONDITION OR AND WHERE IS
THE COMMISSION MUST ENGAGE AND
AN EXTENSIVE HEARING PROCESS
STATE LAW REQUIRES LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HOLD JUST ONE PUBLIC
HEARING PRIOR TO ADOPTING A MAP.
THERE'S NO PUBLIC AVERAGE
REQUIREMENTS.
AS A REULT MANY COMMUNITIES AND
ESPECIALLY NON ENGLISH SPEAKING
COMMUNITIES I DO NOT FAIL TO
PARTICIPATE IN PROCESS AND MAY
NOT EVEN BE AWARE THAT ITS
CURRENT.
THESE ARE OFTEN COURSE THE SAME
CONSTITUENCIES ARE STARKLY
ALREADY STARKLY UNDER
REPRESENTED IN MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
IF YOU FOUR NINE FOR MAPS ACT
PROVIDES POLICY GUARDRAILS TO
STOP THE WORSE THESE ABUSES.
IT OFFICE MANDATORY RANKS
REDUCING CRITERIA MODEL CLOSELY
OFF THE STATE CRITERIA WHICH
PRIORITIZE KEEPING NEIGHBORHOODS
AND COMMUNITIES INTACT.
IT ALSO REQUIRES MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION INCLUDING MINIMAL
FOR HEARINGS FOR MAP CAN BE
APPROVED.
IN A REQUIREMENT THAT CITIES AND
COUNTIES ENGAGING BASIC CAMINO
READS SO DIVERSE CONSTITUENCIES
INCLUDING NON ENGLISH SPEAKING
ONES.
HAVE A VOICE IN THIS PROCESS.
TOGETHER WE THINK THE CHANGES
MAYBE EIGHT FOUR NINE WILL
CONTRIBUTE TO MORE
REPRESENTATIVE INCLUSIVE AND
ACCOUNTABLE LOCAL MOXIE.
ALL THESE REASONS WERE PROUD --
TO TONIGHT VOTE ON AB.
EIGHT FOUR NINE AND AS A SPONSOR
JUST LIKE CLOSE ALSO ECHOING THE
COMMENTS OF THE SUMMER BONTA --
IN EXPRESSING GRATITUDE TOWARDS
LEAGUE OF CITIES AND SEE
SACRIFICE VERY PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSIONS -- TOWARDS POTENTIAL
MEMON STRESSING THE BURDENS
CONCERNS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THEM THIS
BILL PROCEEDS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THE MORNING.
AMBERG I'M GONNA TAG TEAM WITH
SEVERE GARCIA FROM DILLER SQUARE
TOUGH AND ASIAN I'M DOOR ROSE
WITH LEGAL AND VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA CO SPONSOR IN IN
SUPPORT.
SO AS YOU KNOW THE LEAGUE HELPED
LEAD THE FIGHT FOR STATE.
LEVEL REDISTRICTING AND ALL THE
CRITERIA OF THAT INCLUDES OUR
LOCAL LEAGUES WORK HARD TO
ENSURE THAT LOCAL REDISTRICTING
PROCESS IS TRANSPARENT.
THE PUBLIC CORPORATE DECISIONS
REALLY ROBUST AND AND MEANINGFUL.
THAT EVERY COMMUNITIES ENGAGED
IN THAT PROCESS SO THAT THE LINE
DRAWING RESULT IN A FAIR
REPRESENTATION OF THE DIVERSITY
IN THE AREA.
BUT IT IS A SISYPHUS IN STRUGGLE
WHEN DISTRICT MAPS ARE DRAFTED
INTRODUCED IN THE DOCTOR ALL AT
ONCE WITHOUT FIRST BEING
PUBLISHED AND SHARED WITH THE
PUBLIC THERE'S JUST NO ROOM FOR
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION.
OR WHEN THERE'S NO HARD STANDARD
REQUIRING THAT CITIES AND
COUNTIES REDISTRICT WITH A FOCUS
ON KEEPING COMMUNITIES INTACT WE
CONSIDER TO BE CRITICAL.
OR A MAJORITY MINORITY STATE BUT
AS NICHOLAS TESTIFIED WE DON'T
SEE THAT DIVERSITY REPRESENTED
AT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT LEVEL.
WE NEED TO INSTITUTIONALIZE
PUBLIC OUTREACH TO MAKE LINE
DRYING AND INCLUSIVE EXERCISE WE
NEED TO BE ACCESSIBLE TO PEOPLE
WHOSE FIRST LANGUAGE MAY NOT BE
ENGLISH.
OF THE WORK WITH THAT WE DO AT
THE STATE LEVEL PROVIDES A CLEAR
NATIONAL STANDARD OF EXCELLENCE
SO NOW IT'S TIME TO FIX
REDISTRICTING IN CITIES AND
COUNTIES BY REQUIRING THAT SAME
KIND OF TRANSPARENCY.
BY LAYING IT ALL OUT IN IN A IN
A FAIR -- AND TRANSPARENT MANNER
IT [inaudible]
END OF CREATING CONSISTENT
CRITERIA WHICH IS A BIG PART OF
WHAT THIS BILL DOES. FOR THE
LOCALITIES TO BE ABLE TO USED TO
BE HAVE SOMETHING TO HANG THEIR
HAT ON SO WE HOPE THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO JOIN US IN SUPPORTING
A. B. -- A FORTY NINE AND TO
BRING CALIFORNIA ONE STEP CLOSER
TO REALLY A MORE REPRESENTATIVE
DEMOCRACY WITH ATTITUDE EVERY
DISAPPEAR.
HELLO OUR MOTION THANK YOU HI MY
NAME IS SEVERE SEE I'M WITH THE
DOORS WERE THE FOUNDATION AS A
G. I. S. ANALYST.
I'M HERE REALLY SPEAKING FOR HOW.
GREAT THIS BILL WOULD BE EN
PROVIDING A LOT OF RESOURCES FOR
THE COMMUNITY I WE'VE BEEN IN
PART OF A COUPLE OF
REDISTRICTING EFFORTS IN THE
COUNTY OF KERN.
AND BECAUSE WE HAVE THE J. S.
DEPARTMENT AT THE DEALERS WERE
THE FOUNDATION WERE ABLE TO TELL
OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
ABOUT THE DATA ABOUT THE
REDISTRICTING PROCESS BECAUSE IT
IS A PRETTY COMPLICATED PROCESS
AND BY HAVING AN IN HOUSE --
DEPARTMENT WERE ABLE TO GUARD TO
THE COMMUNITY AND REALLY
ADVOCATE FOR THESE MAPS AND SO
AB EIGHT FOUR NINE OUT WOULD A
PARTNER WITH GOOD GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE DOORS
WERE THE FOUNDATION AND OTHER.
PARTNER AGREES ASIANS LIKE
OURSELVES WHO ALREADY GO TO
THESE DISTRICT MEETINGS AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL AT THE CITY LEVEL
AND THEN WILL ABLE.
TO BUY WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
EN MASSE -- THIS COMMUNITY
MEMBERS TO GO AND LEARN ABOUT
THIS REDISTRICTING PROCESS THE
LANGUAGE ACCESS M. IS ALSO A
REALLY IMPORTANT PART HERE
BECAUSE THERE'S NOT ONLY A
HEAVILY SPEAKING OF SPANISH
POPULATION IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND KERN COUNTY
PARTICULAR.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE OTHER I'M
COMMUNITIES LIKE THE PUNJAB BE
COMMUNITY WHICH WHEN THEY GO TO
THESE MEETINGS AND THEY DON'T
HAVE LANGUAGE AREN'T REALLY ABLE
TO ONE UNDERSTAND WHAT PEOPLE
ARE SAYING BUT ALSO.
JUST UNDERSTAND THAT
REDISTRICTING PROCESS AS WELL
AND ALSO BEING A DATA PERSON WE
REALLY KNOW HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
TO PROVIDE THOSE MAPS AND THAT
DATA BE TRANSPARENT WITH THE
PUBLIC.
AND ALLOW FOR THEM -- AS A GOOD
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATION TO
REVIEW THOSE MAPS WITH THEIR
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO REALLY TELL
THEM IF THAT THE VERY AS A FAX
OF YOU KNOW ONE LINE GOING ABOVE
A COMMUNITY OR OR GOING BY LAW --
BELOW AND IN TERMS OF GOING INTO
THE DATA -- SO WE WE ARE REALLY
EXCITED AND AND HOPE THAT --
THAT THIS BILL AB EIGHT FOUR
NINE WILL PASS BECAUSE IT WILL
BE A GREAT EFFORT FOR THE
COMMUNITY AND WILL REALLY ALLOW
FOR THEM TO BE A PART OF THIS
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA -- THE WE
NOW HAVE A FULL COMPLIMENT SO
LET'S GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH A
ONE YEAH.
NUMBER HERE NUMBER HERE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HERE HERTZBERG PRISONER
HERE LEYVA.
LEYVA HERE STERN STERN HERE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A QUORUM --
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
FREE TO WALLACE WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
HI AND THAT ADDED I WITH THE
MEXICAN AMERICAN LEGAL DEFENSE
AND EDUCATIONAL FUND IN SUPPORT.
SOMEONE TALK WITH A CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF UNITED LATIN AMERICAN
CITIZENS AND STRONG SUPPORTER
THIS BILL BECAUSE WE FEEL.
IT WILL GIVE US AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PARTNER WITH LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO AND TO ROUTE.
HAPPENED A GREATER MORE
INCLUSIVE ELECTORAL PROCESS.
AT THE CURRENT LINE CALIFORNIA
MANY CAMPAIGN IN SUPPORT.
YES IN MARTINEZ WITH ME FOR ME
LEVEL TO IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IN OPPOSITION ANY IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MORNING SIR MORNING SURE MEMBERS
DâN HUTCHINGS REPRESENTING THE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES --
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IN
PRINT AS OF TODAY -- REALLY DO
WANT AG -- FIRST OFF GIVE --
SPECIAL THANKS TO YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF WITH A VERY ACCURATE NOW
ANALYSIS REFLECTING SOME OF THE
CONCERNS WE'VE OUTLINED WITH THE
SPONSORS AND THE AND THE AUTHOR --
SECONDARILY ONE OF COURSE THINK
THE AUTHOR AND AND THE SPONSORS
FOR FOR DILIGENTLY WORKING WITH
US I'M I THINK PRIMARILY OUR
CONCERNS REALLY DO RESONATE WITH
REGARDS TO THE COST AND THE MAN
THAT THE UNFUNDED MANDATES WE'VE
HAD -- DECADES OF SUSPENDED
ELECTION MANDATES -- AND AND
QUITE FRANKLY WHEN WE LOOK AT
ALL THINGS CONCERNED WITH WITH
THE LOCAL REVENUE DECREASING AND
NOT BEING ABLE TO MAKE YOU KNOW
MAN ON MINIMUM PAYMENTS ON
PENSION LIABILITIES AND OTHER
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT ARE REALLY
TAKING THE DAY.
HAVING YET ANOTHER UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES A CHALLENGE THAT
BEING SAID WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
GET TO A PLACE WE WE FEEL
COMFORTABLE -- AND AND HOPEFULLY
WE CAN WE CAN FIND A RESOLUTION --
PRIOR -- TO THE BILL GETTING OUT
TO OF GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE SO
WHEN I THINK THE AUTHORS
SPONSORS HOPEFULLY WE CAN GET
THERE.
URINE OPTIMISTIC OPPOSITION
OPTIMISTIC OPPOSITION WOULD BE
ACCURATE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST
JEAN HER SEARCH AND WE HAVE FOR
THE URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO HEAR AN OPTIMISTIC
OPPOSITION.
WE TOO I APPRECIATE THE WORK OF
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSOR AND
HELPING US GET TO A PLACE WHERE
YOU CAN FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH
THE LANGUAGE SO WE LOOK FORWARD.
TO THAT THANK YOU BUT OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION. ONE IS REVENUE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION
OF COUNTIES AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AT THE TABLE.
ALSO AN OPTIMISTIC OPPOSITION.
OKAY.
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AT THIS POINT AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA AND I KNOW
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING DILIGENTLY
IN FACT AYE AYES YOU TEXTED ME
AT TEN FOURTEEN LAST NIGHT I'M
GLAD TO SEE THE FOLKS IS SIMILAR
GETTING OVERTIME PAY NOW.
SO -- IT ADDRESSING THE THE
CONCERN WITH RESPECT TO EXPENSES
AND AND UNFUNDED MANDATES.
HE WOULD SPEAK TO THAT
[inaudible]
YES TOM.
THERE HAVE BEEN VERY FEW
STANDARDS.
AND RULES AND GUIDELINES THAT
MAKE LOCAL REDISTRICTING FAIR SO.
WE'RE GONNA DO SOMETHING TO
CHANGE THE STATUS QUO THERE WILL
BE SOME COSTS AND SOME BURDENS --
BUT WE DON'T WANT TO JUMP
HEADLONG INTO THOSE CASA BIRDS
WITHOUT BEING THOUGHTFUL AND
BEING REASONABLE WITH.
A BOUNTY THE VALUES THAT THAT
ARE BEING THE GUY THAT'S BEEN
ADDED -- WITH WITH SOME.
DOT THE TO THE COSTS THAT ARE
BEING INCURRED SO.
WE HAVE SHARED WITH YOU AND YOUR
STAFF AND A BLUEPRINT THAT WE
THINK IS A BLUEPRINT THAT SHOULD
WE GET OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE CAN
HELP US.
STRIKE THE RIGHT BALANCE BETWEEN
COSTS -- AND FAIR DEMOCRACY AS
WE GO FORWARD AND WE'RE HOPING
THAT WE COULD TAKE THOSE OF THE
SECOND COMMITTEE AS BEFORE THERE
ARE DISCUSSIONS WITH WITH OUR
WITH THOSE WHO ARE AN OPTIMISTIC.
OPPOSITION AT AT THE MOMENT --
THESE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE --
LOCAL MANDATES THAT THAT ARE
FUNDED AND THAT IS THE INTENTION --
WEEK WE KNOW THAT THAT BUT SOME
OF THE HISTORY HAS BEEN WAS
SUSPENDED MANDATES AND THAT IS
NOT WHAT WE WERE SEEKING TO DO
WE'RE STICKING AFFAIR DEMOCRACY --
BUT WE WE HAVE BEEN THOUGHTFUL I
BELIEVE IN TERMS OF LISTENING TO
THE CONCERNS AND HAVE OPPOSE
QUITE A FEW AMENDMENTS THAT CAN
HELP REDUCE COSTS REDUCE BURDEN.
AND GET TO A PLACE WHERE I HOPE
OUR OPPONENTS WILL BE ABLE TO GO
NEUTRAL [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
PART OF THIS LAW.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE TO ENGAGE
IN REDISTRICTING EVERY TEN YEARS.
YES.
THE CONSTITUTION OF THE UNITED
STATES REQUIRE THAT THEY RE DRAW
THE LINES EVERY TEN YEARS
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
YOU'RE WALKING.
DOES THE YOUR QUESTION AIDED
WITH THAT.
YES THERE ARE HAVE TO DRAW MAPS
YES DO THEY HAVE TO BE
CONSTITUTIONALLY PERMISSIBLE YES.
WHAT'S THE DIFFERENCE.
I SPENT YEARS WORKING ON THE
STUFF YOU KNOW MISTER BONTA IT
FOR THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
I THINK THE ARGUMENT IT'S LIKE
TO ASK A LOCAL GOVERNMENT THAT
THEY GOT TO COUNT VOTES AND
SAYING WELL THAT'S A LOCAL
MANDATE.
IT'S THE CONSTITUTION AND IS THE
BASIS OF GOVERNMENT AND ALL
YOU'RE DOING NOW IS MAKING A
DETERMINATION AND TAKING OUT OF
THE HANDS OF THE ELECTED
POLITICIANS.
WHO ARMED RIGHTLY OR WRONGLY ARE
OFTEN JUDGE IN A WAY OF SELF
DEALING AND WHAT WE'VE LEARNED
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHEN
WE'VE HAD THESE COMMISSIONS AND
WE'VE LOOKED AT THE LAWS OF THE
LAST FIFTY YEARS OF THE SUPREME
COURT CASES?
THE MANDATED ALL OF THE
CONTIGUOUS NATURES AND
COMMUNITIES OF INTEREST AND ALL
THE LAWS.
THAT THIS ISN'T REALLY THAT MUCH
DIFFERENT AND THAT ALL IT'S
DOING IS CHANGING A PROCESS THAT
WOULD EXIST IN ANY OF IT AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BECAUSE
THEY'RE GONNA DRAW.
AND THEN I THINK THE ARGUMENTS
ABOUT COSTS ARE DISINGENUOUS AND
THAT THEY BECAUSE THERE ARE
COSTS THEY'RE GONNA HAVE TO DO
MAPS ARE GOING TO HAVE TO
EVERYTHING ELSE THE QUESTION IS.
WHO DOES IT?
AND IS IT ARE YOU SAYING THAT
YOU GOT TO DO OUT REACH AND TALK
TO THE FOLKS IN THE COMMUNITY IN
ORDER TO GET INPUT.
IS THAT SOMETHING WHERE THE
GOVERNMENT IS MAKING A MANDATE
THAT SOUND REASONABLE AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE CONSTITUTION
WE'RE JUST TELLING PEOPLE YOU
GOT TO DO YOUR JOB THAT YOU
CAN'T DO IT IN THE BACK ROOM
THAT YOU GOT TO CHANGE UP THE
GAME.
AND SO I THINK THAT WE HAVE SEEN
THIS WORK IN A PRETTY BRILLIANT
WAY.
THE ARGUMENTS THAT YOU KNOW
PARTISANSHIP BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AREN'T
PARTISAN BUT IF YOU LOOK AT ALL
THE OTHER CONSTITUTIONAL CASES
THAT HAVE BEEN LITERALLY FIFTY
YEARS SINCE THE VOTING RIGHTS
ACT IN. NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
SEVEN FORM THIS PROCESS I DON'T
BELIEVE YOU DO A THING THAT'S
ADVERSE TO WILL THIS OR IMPOSING
ANY OBLIGATION.
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE
ARGUMENTS ABOUT THIS WILL AFFECT
THEIR PENSION CONTRIBUTIONS IS
THEIR ARGUMENT IT'S ABOUT POWER.
AND SIMPLE AND THIS IS A GREAT
PROCESS TO GREAT BILL THANKS FOR
BRINGING FORWARD I LOVE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE AND I LOVE TO MAKE THE
MOTION THE TIME APPROPRIATE
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
RIGHT OF THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG I'D LIKE TO HAVE YOU
AS A CO AUTHOR THANK YOU FOR THE
MOTION.
THANK YOU SEVEN HERTZBERG ASSUME
THAT THAT WAS QUESTIONS HE SAID
ISN'T IT TRUE AT THE SO -- I
DON'T KNOW THERE'S A THE RESPOND
TO BUT ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
WOULD LIKE TO RESPOND
[inaudible]
I MEAN.
I WHAT I I THINK EVERYTHING
WE'RE DOING IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE CONSTITUTION.
WE ARE PROVIDING SPECIFIC
STANDARDS IN AND RULES THAT I
THINK.
A TEASE OUT -- WHAT IS
SPECIFICALLY SHOULD BE THAT WERE
BEING PRESCRIPTIVE I THINK
WITHOUT BEING OVERLY
PRESCRIPTIVE I I DO AGREE THAT --
THERE ARE COSTS AND THERE IS
WORK TO BE DONE TO ENSURE A
STRONG DEMOCRACY.
AND THIS IS PART OF THAT
SOMETIMES I'VE BEEN FAIR AND
HONORING OUR DEMOCRACY -- TAKES
EFFORT AND AND TAKES COSTS SO --
I APPRECIATE SENATOR HERTZBERG
PASSIONATE SUPPORT OF THE BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IN TERMS OF OF THIS BILL THIS
BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE ANY
JURISDICTION TO FOR EXAMPLE HAVE
DISTRICT ELECTIONS CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT AND THE ARE YOU
CONCERNED THAT THIS MAY BE A
DISINCENTIVE FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO ADOPT -- BY
DISTRICT ELECTIONS. ONE COMING
ON THE ROAD.
SENDER I'D I DON'T THINK THIS
BILL WILL BEAR ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER AS TO THE DECISION OF
DISTRICTS THE MAIN DRIVER FROM
MOVING TO DISTRICTS AS MEN.
I CHALLENGES RELATING TO
MINORITY REPRESENTATION AND IT
HASN'T BEEN SO I DON'T THINK THE
THE PROCEDURES FOR DRAWING THE
DISTRICTS WILL NECESSARILY
AFFECT.
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE OF THE HERTZBERG WAS
GOING TO MOVE -- TURNER STERN
MOVES ALL RIGHT -- THEM --
THIRTY SORRY.
HEY I THINK YOUR POINT IS WELL I
I THINK THAT WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
DRIVE THE DECISION IN CENTER
DISINCENTIVE DECISION.
TO GO TO DISTRICT ALEXIS WE
THINK THAT HAPPENS BASED ON A
DIFFERENT STANDARD OF DIFFERENT
APARTMENTS HI BUT ONCE THE
DISTRICT ELECTIONS ARE IN PLAY
WHEN REDISTRICTING WE THINK WE
HAVE A AND AN APPROPRIATE
APPROACH TO HOW THAT SHOULD BE
DONE FAIRLY AND AND
DEMOCRATICALLY.
THANKS FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
APPRECIATE THE ROBUST DISCUSSION
I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR -- THANKS
AND I KNOW IT IS YOU YOU
MENTIONED DOES MENTION YOU
WORKING HARD ON THIS AND I KNOW
YOU'LL KEEP PARK.
COMMITTEE STAFF INFORMED AS TO
THE PROGRESS.
WE WILL I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ALL RIGHT -- MA'AM SIR TO BE
CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS A GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE NUMBER.
NUMBER I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE STERN.
STERN I THANK YOU ARMS BONTA
WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE ROLE OPEN
OF FOR CENTER HERTZBERG AR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF
.
SO I ICE I THOUGHT I SAW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW HERE A
MOMENT AGO -- SORE PAGING
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS LOW AND BERMAN.
IS TO TAKE UP THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BEFORE SENATOR STERN
LEAVES ALL RIGHT.
IS THERE MOTION SOME OF THE
STERN MOST OF MADAME SECTOR IF
YOU CALL THE ROLL NUMBER HI
NUMBER I NIELSEN.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
NIELSEN I HERTZBERG.
LABOR.
LABOR I STERN STERN I
THE NUMBER
BERMAN WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
[inaudible]
SO.
MMHM BERMAN YOU HAVE THREE BILLS --
SHOW STAR WITH AB FIVE OH FOUR
TO START WITH THAT WOULD BE
GREAT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
SANDERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
BEFORE I BEGIN I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR ASSISTANCE IN
ACCOMMODATING THE AMENDMENT THAT
IS ON ONE OF THE BOTTOM OF PAGES.
PAGE EIGHT OF THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS WHICH I'M HAPPY TO
ACCEPT AS AN AUTHORS AMENDMENT.
STATE AND FEDERAL LAW REQUIRE
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS TO CONDUCT
PERIODIC RESIDENCY CONFIRMATION
PROGRAMS TO VERIFY THE ADDRESSES
OF REGISTERED VOTERS.
IF THE ELECTIONS OFFICIAL
RECEIVES INFORMATION FROM THE US
POSTAL SERVICE THE INDICATES
THAT A VOTER HAS MOVED.
THAT VOTERS REGISTRATION BECOMES
INACTIVE IN THE ELECTIONS
OFFICIAL SENDS A NOTIFICATION TO
THE VOTERS LAST KNOWN ADDRESS.
THE INACTIVE LIST VOTER SERVICES
SAFEGUARDS TO PROTECT VOTERS
FROM BEING DISENFRANCHISED DUE
TO INACCURATE INFORMATION WHILE
ALSO ENSURING THAT ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS HAVE THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO KEEP VOTER REGISTRATION
RECORDS UP TO DATE.
VOTERS REGISTRATION IS AN ACTIVE
REMAINS ELIGIBLE TO VOTE BUT
DOES NOT RECEIVE ELECTIONS
RELATED MATERIALS IN THE MAIL.
AN INACTIVE VOTER REGISTRATION
EVENTUALLY MAYBE CANCEL THE
VOTER DOES NOT VOTE OVER THE
COURSE OF APPROXIMATELY A FOUR
YEAR PERIOD.
IN KEEPING WITH THE STATE'S
COMMITMENT TO DEVELOPING
POLICIES THAT PROTECT THE RIGHTS
OF VOTERS.
AB FIVE OH FOUR EXPANDS THE
TOOLS THAT MAY BE USED TO
CONFIRM THE RESIDENTS ADDRESS OF
REGISTERED VOTERS.
SPECIFICALLY AB FIVE OH FOUR
PROVIDES THAT IF VOTER CONFIRMS
THEIR ADDRESS BY LOGGING INTO
THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S MY
VOTER STATUS WEBSITE.
THAT CONFIRMATION AN SHORES THAT
THE VOTERS REGISTRATION REMAINS
ACTIVE OR MAKES THE REGISTRATION
ACTIVE AGAIN IF IT WAS AN ACTIVE.
AB FIVE OH FOUR ALSO ENSURES THE
VOTERS REGISTRATIONS ARE NOT
MADE IN ACTIVE UNLESS THE
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL RECEIVES
INFORMATION.
FROM A GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY THAT
INDICATES THAT THE VOTER HAS
MOVED. TO ENSURE CONSISTENT
APPLICATION THROUGHOUT THE STATE
AB FIVE OH FOUR ALSO CLARIFIES
RESIDENCY CONFIRMATION
PROCEDURES THAT COUNTY ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS MUST FOLLOW.
SB FIVE OH FOUR IS SPONSORED BY
SECRETARY OF STATE -- EXPEDIA
AND IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CLERKS
IN ELECTIONS OFFICIALS IN THE
AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION
OF CALIFORNIA.
AMONG OTHERS IT HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY AS TO
FREE MARKET FROM THE OFFICE OF
SECRETARY OF STATE OUT EXPEDIA.
MORNING TURN MEMBERS THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY --
TO VOICE OUR SUPPORT AS NOTED
THE SECRETARY SUPPORTS IS
MEASURED INSURER.
LIST MAINTENANCE OF ORDER
REGISTER FOR OUR VOTER
REGISTRATION DATABASE AND A
CLEAR PROCESS TO UPDATE RELEVANT
INFORMATION THIS BILL FURTHER
INSURERS VOTERS MAY HAVE THE
CONVENIENCE OF CONFIRMING OR
UPDATE THEIR UPDATING THE
RESIDENCY ADDRESS THROUGH THE
AGENCY'S WEBSITE. FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ORDER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
LEGAL VOTERS OF CALIFORNIANS
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS.
RACHEL WALLACE ACLU CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORT.
MY LONGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF CLOCKS AND
WATCHES OFFICIALS IN SUPPORT.
I'M A JURY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES
ADVOCACY.
FROM SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE LET'S BRING BACK
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS. ELEVEN THE
NIELSEN SO IN THE I'VE BEEN JUST
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS -- MISS
MARKET AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN I UNDERSTAND YOU BOTH
HAVE EXPERIENCE IN ELECTIONS.
WITH RESPECT TO EACH OTHER IS.
WE GO BACK A LITTLE WAYS.
YEAH -- YEAH DID YOU HAVE WILL
NEVER RUN AGAINST EACH OTHER
THAT'S A THAT'S A FACTUALLY.
ORDINATED TO ENSURE THAT.
WE HAD A AS AMICABLE AND
SYMBIOTIC RELATIONSHIP THAT I'M
I'M FORM THAT WHATEVER THAT
DISCUSSION WAS IT YOU EMERGE AS
PRESIDENT OF THE STUDENT COUNCIL
IS THAT CORRECT MISS MARK I
BELIEVE AYE SIR THE STUDENT BODY
PRESIDENT ALL STUDENT BODY
PRESIDENT.
AND I WAS HER HER VERY
RESPECTFUL UNDERLING.
AS A SENIOR CLASS PRESIDENT.
YES -- OR EVER HOST OF OUR CLASS
REUNIONS YES.
IF I KNOWN THAT I WOULD HAVE RAN.
OUT OF ALL IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITY ALL RIGHT IT IS
GOING TO CLEAR THAT UP ALL RIGHT.
IN THE MIDDLE THERE ARE AYE --
THAT THAT'S MY ONLY QUESTION WE
WE HAD CHOCOLATE MILK IN EVERY
WATER FOUNTAIN.
AS LIMóN SLIDES ON THE LAWN.
YEAH THAT WAS A PLATFORM REALLY
YEAH OKAY -- THAT IS A FUTURE
LEGISLATION MIGHT BE AND I BY --
THEM SIR DID YOU CALL THE ROLL.
YOU WANNA CLOSE.
AFTER THAT NO ALL RIGHT.
THE CHOCOLATE MILK AND WATER
FOUNTAINS IS ACT AS IT WILL BE A
NEW CLOTHES ARE.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
NUMBER.
BURKE AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN AYE HERTZBERG.
LEYVA Y. LEYVA ICE.
ALRIGHT WE'LL WE'LL KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN.
ALL RIGHT -- A. B.. SIX NINE
THREE THANK YOU I'M A RESEARCHER.
CONDITIONAL VOTER REGISTRATION
ALSO KNOWN AS SAME DAY VOTER
REGISTRATION IS A SAFETY NET FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHO MISSED THE
DEADLINE TO REGISTER TO VOTE OR
UPDATE THE REGISTRATION.
CURRENTLY A CONDITIONAL VOTER IS
GIVEN A PROVISIONAL BALLOT WHICH
IS PROCESS AFTER ELECTION DAY
DURING THE CAMPUS PERIOD.
USING VOTE COUNT THE STATEWIDE
VOTER DATABASE I COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL IS NOW ABLE
TO VERIFY IF A VOTER IS ELIGIBLE
IMMEDIATELY.
AN UPDATE THE DATABASE IN REAL
TIME.
THIS MEANS THE SAME PROCESS TO
VERIFY CONDITIONAL REGISTRANTS
ELIGIBILITY THAT CURRENTLY
OCCURS ON THE BACK AND AFTER
ELECTION DAY CAN SIMPLY HAPPEN
ON THE FRONT END INSTEAD IN REAL
TIME.
THEREFORE EIGHTY SIX NINETY
THREE WOULD AUHORIZE AN
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL TO OFFER A
NON PROVISIONAL OR REGULAR
BALLOT TO A CONDITIONALLY
REGISTERED VOTER.
IF THE OFFICIAL USES VOTE CAL TO
DO THREE THINGS TO DETERMINE THE
VOTERS ELIGIBLE TO VERIFY THE
PERSON HAS NOT VOTED AND CHECK
IF THEY ARE INCLUDED ON A ROSTER
IN ANY OTHER COUNTY.
AND UPDATE THE VOTE COUNT RECORD
TO INDICATE THAT THE PERSON HAS
VOTED.
IF THOSE CONDITIONS ARE NOT MET
OR THE CONNECTION TO THE VOTER
DATABASE IS INTERRUPTED AT ANY
TIME.
THEN THE VOTER WILL BE ISSUED A
PROVISIONAL BALLOT.
THIS BILL WILL IMPROVE THE VOTER
EXPERIENCE AND LOWER THE NUMBER
OF PROVISIONAL BALLOTS THAT NEED
TO BE PROCESSED AFTER ELECTION
DAY.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE -- AND WITH ME IS RYAN
RONCO CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
CLERKS AND ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
AND LOOKS ACTIVITY MARK AS WELL
FROM THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE.
I THANK YOU I CHAIR ON BERGEN
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
RHEIN RONCO PLASTER COUNTY CLERK
RECORDER REGISTRAR OF VOTERS.
AND A CULTURE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF COURSE IN
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS LEGISLATION
COMMITTEE I WOULD BE PLEASED TO
SPONSOR A AB SIX NINETY THREE
AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN.
FIRST WORK ON THIS BILL.
SB SIX NINETY THREE WILL PERMIT
THE USE OF NON PROVISIONAL
BALLOTS FOR CONDITIONAL VOTER
REGISTRATION AND VOTING.
A CERTAIN CONDITIONS ARE MET.
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY ELECTIONS
RAPIDLY APPROACHING THAT THIS
CHANGE WILL ALLOW ELECTION
OFFICIALS THE OPTION TO
IMMEDIATELY ADJUDICATE
CONDITIONALLY REGISTERED VOTERS
BALLOTS.
IN SO DOING IT WILL HELP TO
REDUCE THE MANY CONDITIONALLY
REGISTERED VOTERS PROVISIONAL
BALLOTS THAT WOULD NEED TO BE
REVIEWED PROCESSED AND EDUCATED
DURING THE POST ELECTION CANVAS
PERIOD.
I HAVING EVEN A SMALL NUMBER OF
VOTERS BALLOTS IMMEDIATELY
JUDICATA ENCOUNTERED.
BY CONCLUDING THEIR VOTES IN
ELECTION NIGHT RESULTS.
WE ARE CREATING A BETTER VOTING
EXPERIENCE FOR VOTERS WERE
REDUCING THE NUMBER OF BALLOTS
BEING PROCESSED AFTER ELECTION
DAY WE'RE SPEEDING UP RESULTS
AND WE ARE REDUCING THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON OUR
STRESSED CAMPUS PROCEDURES AND
TIMELINE.
IF THERE'S ANY AMBIGUITY ABOUT A
VOTERS ELIGIBILITY OR FOR
COMMUNICATION WITH THE STATEWIDE
DATABASE IS INTERRUPTED AT ANY
TIME THE VOTERS BALLOT WILL BE
PLACED INTO AN ENVELOPE FOR
EDUCATION LATER.
WHEN WE CAN CONFIRM THE VOTERS
ELIGIBILITY ABOUT?
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
DRIVE OUT.
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE THANK YOU SIR MADAM
PRESIDENT.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF FOR THE
REASONS STATED WE ORDER SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SENATOR PRESENT IN THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
YOUR ROSE THE RIVER IS A
CALIFORNIANS.
A MAJORITY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CIVIL LIBERTIES ARE
ADVOCACY.
FRONT SUPPORT THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
YES MA'AM.
SURE GO AHEAD.
COME OF THE TABLE LIKE.
AND I KNOW THAT -- THE LETTER IS
BEING PRESENTED TO EACH MEMBER
OF THE COMMITTEE.
YES THEY ARE IN A MY NAME IS
CALLING BRITAIN I'M WITH THE
ELECTION INTEGRITY PROJECT
CALIFORNIA.
AND THIS IS OUR OUR LETTER OF
OPPOSITION.
OUR ORGANIZATION STRONGLY
OPPOSES AB.
SIX NINETY THREE WE BELIEVE THAT
IT WOULD FACILITIES FACILITATE
HEIRONEOUS REGISTRATIONS AND
ENSURE THAT INELIGIBLE VOTES
WOULD BE CAST AND COUNTED.
OUR OUR MAIN ISSUE WITH THIS IS
THAT SOUL SOUL RELIANCE ON THE
VOTE CAL.
A DATABASE WE BELIEVE THAT IT IS
AS YET ON RELIABLE PURVEYOR OF
SOUL VERIFICATION OF ELIGIBILITY
TO VOTE.
IN THE I. T. N. -- TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN HAD A LAWSUIT WITH
CALIFORNIA.
OF THE OVER THE VOTER ROLLS AND
THEY HAVE VOTER ROLLS HAVE
SUFFERED FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS
OF MAINTENANCE NEGLECT.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT IT WILL TAKE
YEARS TO COME INTO FULL
COMPLIANCE WITH THE FEDERAL LAW.
AND UNTIL THAT COMPLIANCE IS
COMPLETE WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT
VOTE CAL CAN BE RELIED UPON AS A
SOLE SOURCE OF VALIDATION FOR
REGISTRATION OR ELIGIBILITY AND
WE HAVE SOME EXAMPLES THAT WE
LIKE THE COMMITTEE SERVES TO PAY
ATTENTION.
TO ARE USING LA COUNTY IN
FEBRUARY. TWENTY TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DATA.
I WON'T GO INTO ALL THE DETAILS
BUT THERE WERE OVERSIX THOUSAND
SEATS.
MUST ALSO VOTERS THAT WERE
LIKELY REGISTERED TO MORE THAN
ONE ADDRESS AT THE SAME TIME
[inaudible]
OF THERE WERE SEVEN THOUSAND
ALMOST EIGHT THOUSAND SETS OF
VOTERS THAT OR LIKELY REGISTERED
IN TWO DIFFERENT ADDRESSES IN
WITH IN LOS ANGELES.
AND THERE WERE OVER OF FOUR
THOUSAND RATE ASSESSOR VOTERS
THAT WERE REGISTERED IN LA
COUNTY.
AND THE OTHER NEIGHBORING
COUNTIES.
IN ADDITION TO THAT THERE WERE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY SIX LIKELY DISEASE VOTERS
ON THE LA COUNTY ROLES.
OF 50% OF WHOM HAD DIED WITHIN
THE COUNTY BUT WE'RE STILL ON
THE ROLLS.
THESE ARE JUST JUST SOME
EXAMPLES AND THERE'S MORE.
LOW CAL IS ALSO MISSING
IMPORTANT INFORMATION NEEDED TO
DETERMINE VOTER ELIGIBILITY.
AND DISTINGUISH ONE APPLICATION
FROM THE OTHER.
HOW ARE USING THE SAME VOTE
HELICITY I. P. C. A DATA ANALYST
IDENTIFIED SIXTY NINE THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED AND EIGHTY LA COUNTY
REGISTRANTS WITH NO ACCURATE
DATE OF BIRTH?
ALMOST TEN THOUSAND LA COUNTY
RESIDENTS WITH MISSING FIRST
NAMES.
AND SIX HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN LA
COUNTY REGISTRANTS MISSING THEIR
LAST NAMES.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW REASONS
THAT WE BELIEVE VOEPEL COULD NOT
BE RELIED UPON AS THE SOLE
SOURCE. FOR VALIDATION OF
REGISTRATION ELIGIBILITY -- ONE
OTHER FELLOW SEE IN THE IN THIS
BILL IS THAT AB SIXTY NINE DOES
NOT INDICATE HOW ELECTION DAY
DECISIONS WILL BE MADE.
THERE'S NO MENTION OF THE SEARCH
CRITERIA TO BE USED WOULD BE
DATE OF BIRTH LAST NAME FIRST
NAME.
ARE THESE ARE QUESTIONABLE
CRITERIA GIVEN THAT VOTE CAL HAS
BEEN SHOWN UNABLE TO IDENTIFY
PEOPLE.
REGISTERED SEVERAL TIMES IN ONE
SINGLE ADDRESS.
SEARCH CRITERIA CANNOT RELY ON
DRIVER'S LICENSE NUMBERS EITHER.
AS CALIFORNIA ALONG THESE VOTERS
TO REGISTER WITH NO ID -- ALL
QUALIFIED REGISTERED REGISTRANTS
DESERVE TO CAST A VOTE AND HAVE
IT COUNTED.
THEY DESERVE TO VOTE WITHIN A
SYSTEM THAT PROVIDES THEIR VOTE
FROM BEING DILUTED BY HASTILY
ACCEPTED VOTES THAT MAY NOT BE A
LEGITIMATE.
LAST MINUTE REGISTRANTS MUST BE
SUBJECT TO THE AME LEVEL OF
SCRUTINY AS ALL OTHERS AND UNTIL
ALL PROPER PROCEDURES CAN BE
FOLLOWED.
THEY MUST BE ALLOWED TO CAST
ONLY A PROVISIONAL BALLOT.
AB SIXTY NINE MAYBE THE GREATEST
THREAT TO ELECTION INTEGRITY IN
CALIFORNIA.
AN E. I. PCA STRONGLY OPPOSES
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MA'AM A NOTE FROM THE
LETTER USE DISTRIBUTED YOU'VE
IDENTIFIED AS AS IS ALSO
INDICATED YOUR ORAL TESTIMONY A
NUMBER OF ISSUES THAT YOU
BELIEVE DEMONSTRATE
IRREGULARITIES IS THAT RIGHT
THAT'S CORRECT AND WHEN YOU.
FOUND THIS INFORMATION WHAT DID
YOU DO WITH THE INFORMATION THEY
PASSED IT ON TO THE REGISTER OF
VOTERS.
IN EACH OF THE COUNTIES IN EACH
OF THE COUNTY CS THAT AND WAS
THERE ANY RESPONSE A WELL.
WE FILED SUIT AGAINST THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND THE
REGISTER OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FOR FAILING TO MAINTAIN THEIR
VOTER DATABASES ACCURATELY.
OKAY AND THEY WON THAT
SETTLEMENT.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
HERE WE GO.
MY NAME IS GLEN MYERS SAID LIVE
IN ROSEVILLE AND I'M REGISTERED
TO VOTE I'VE WORKED ON POLLS ON
ELECTION DAY.
I'M A CONCERNED CITIZEN.
IT IS THE MANY YEARS OF VOTER
ROLLS MAINTENANCE THE COLLECT
THAT HAVE NOT YET BEEN CLEANED.
VOTE CALLOUS NOT COMPETENT TO
PREVENT.
VIED ACCURATE INFORMATION.
HOW WILL THE ELECTION OFFICIAL
NO THIS IS THE CORRECT PERSON OR
THAT THE INFORMATION PROVIDED ON
VOTE CAL THESE EVEN CORRECT IF
THE NAME SHOWS UP INFO CAL?
IF THE PERSON HAS NEVER VOTED OR
NOT VOTED IN THIS PRECINCT IT
WILL BE IMPOSSIBLE TO VERIFY
THEIR INFORMATION ON THE SPOT.
THAT IS PRESENTLY RESEARCH IN MY
COUNTY AND VERIFIED AND THE
REGISTRAR'S OFFICE.
THIS PROCEDURAL MAKE MORE WORK
FOR THE ELECTION OFFICIALS AND
WILL IMPACT THEIR ABILITY TO
WORK CAREFULLY IN ASCERTAINING
IF THIS PERSON SHOULD GET ON NON
PROVISIONAL OR PROVISIONAL
BALLOT.
ESPECIALLY IN THE EARLY MORNING
AND EVENING HOURS WHEN MOST
PEOPLE COME TO VOTE I URGE YOU
TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
A BRING BACK COMMITTEE QUESTIONS --
QUESTIONS.
SOME OF THE RIVER MUCH LIKE
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SB SIX
NINETY THREE WOULD NOT
COMPROMISE ELECTION INTEGRITY
THE PROCESS OF THIS BILL
PROPOSES IS THE EXACT SAME
PROCESS THAT STAFF.
IN COUNTY OFFICES FOLLOW TO
CONFIRM A VOTERS ELIGIBILITY
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
ANYTHING ABOUT THE CONDITIONAL
VOTER REGISTRATION PROCESS IT
JUST CHANGES WHEN THAT PROCESS
CAN OCCUR.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU -- LEYVA MOVES I'M
CERTAINLY CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DO PASS NUMBER.
NUMBER GUY NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG.
LEYVA LEYVA AYE STERN.
I WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN THANK
YOU BYE YOU'VE GOT ONE MORE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN -- A. B..
SEVENTEEN OH SEVEN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN SENATORS
EXISTING AND EMERGING TECHNOLOGY
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO PUT
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION AT THE
FINGERTIPS OF VOTERS.
MAKING MAKING VOTING EASIER AND
ENHANCE VOTER ENGAGEMENT.
VOTER CAN RECEIVE THE STATE
VOTER INFORMATION GUIDE
ELECTRONICALLY BRING UP THE
GUIDE ON A SMARTPHONE OR TABLET
AND IMMEDIATELY ACCESS
INFORMATION SUCH AS DONORS TO A
MEASURE.
IN ADDITION LOS ANGELES COUNTY
IS WORKING ON A NEW VOTING
SYSTEM WITH THE OPTION FOR
VOTERS TO SCAN IN QR CODE IT
BALLOTS.
FROM THEIR PHONE TO THE VOTING
TERMINALS AT POLLING PLACES.
HOWEVER OUR ELECTION LAWS DO NOT
EXPLICITLY RECOGNIZE THE USE OF
SMARTPHONES OR TABLETS.
AND SOME ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
IMPORTERS OF QUESTION THE
PERMISSIBILITY OF USING
SMARTPHONES OR TABLETS AT THE
POLLS.
AB SEVENTY NINE SEVEN WOULD
CLARIFY THAT A PERSON MAY NOT BE
PROHIBITED FROM USING AN
ELECTRONIC DEVICE AT A POLLING
PLACE.
PROVIDED THAT THE USE DOES NOT
CONFLICT WITH EXISTING LAWS THAT
ENSURE THAT VOTING IS PRIVATE
AND FREE FROM INTIMIDATION.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME IS TO FRAME
OFTEN SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE.
BLOCK.
THANK YOU FOR THE REASONS STATED
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION.
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY SIR LEYVA
MA'AM SECTOR IF YOU CALL THE
ROLL -- I'M SORRY WOULD LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECT AS YOU ARE ABOUT
THANK YOU OR GO.
MOTION IS TO PASS NUMBER.
NUMBER AYE NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG.
LEYVA LEYVA I AND STERN.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WILL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- A. N..
I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW HERE --
THIS IS OUR LAST BILL SO.
IF THE SENATOR STERN OR
HERTZBERG.
IS WITHIN EARSHOT TO BE A GOOD
TIME TO COME BACK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF YOU HAVE SEEN THIS
BILL BEFORE THIS IS AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY ONE WITH RESPECT TO THE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
ON THE DIRECT DEMOCRACY
INITIATIVE PROCESS BY ENTERING
THE COUNT BILLION DISCLOSURES.
OF COLLECTING SIGNATURES AND
ENSURING THAT THIS IS A
GRASSROOTS EFFORT WITH ME THAT'S
THAT'S FINE SUPPORT IS ALSO
PRETTY BERMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CRISTINA MONEY HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
POLICE TO BE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE WE HAVE SUPPORTED
THIS MEASURES IT BEEN BEFORE
THIS HOUSE AND THE OTHER HOUSE.
MULTIPLE YEARS -- YOU KNOW THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS HAS WAS
REFORMED MANY DECADES AGO -- AT
THE URGING OF THE VOTERS BECAUSE
IT.
THE YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE CAN
OVERCOME BY INTERESTS AND THE
PEOPLE HAVE NOT BEEN HEARD AND
NOW WE HAVE AN INITIATIVE
PROCESS.
HAS BEEN OVERCOME BY INTERESTS
AND THERE'S RARELY OF MOVEMENT
BEHIND AN ISSUE THAT GETS TO OUR
BALLOT WE'D LIKE THERE. TO BE.
JUST A MINOR DEMONSTRATION OF A
MOVEMENT IN THAT 10% A SIGNATURE
TO BE GATHERED BY THOSE WHO
BELIEVE IN ISSUE THAT THEY'RE
WORKING ON A VOLUNTEERING IN
THAT REGARD.
I KNOW THAT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IS WORKING WITH OUR LABOR
PARTNERS TO TO MAKE SURE THIS
BILL IS WORKABLE FOR ALL
CONSTITUENCIES AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN VERS
MUCH TIGHTER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION WE DON'T HAVE
AN OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL
THE WE'VE COSPONSORED VERY
SIMILAR ONE IN THE PAST.
WE DON'T OF DECISION THIS TIME
AS A RESULT OF SOME CONCERNS
RAISED BY AFFILIATES BUT WE'VE
GOT A CONCEPTUAL AGREEMENT ON
SOME AMENDMENTS TO DEAL WITH
THOSE CONCERNS IT'S OVER WORKING
WITH AUTHORS OFFICE TO ADDRESS
THOSE AND CAN HOPEFULLY COME ON
IN SUPPORT.
THANKS THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION
.
THE MORNING MISTER CHAIR.
YES OVER THERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
WELCOME TO CAL CHAMBER
APPRECIATES THE GOAL PROVIDING
OPPOSE
BECAUSE IT WOULD CREATE AN
UNNECESSARY LIMIT ON THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS.
ARTICLE TWO SECTION ONE OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION PROTECTS
THE ABILITY OF CALIFORNIANS
PARTICIPATE DIRECT DEMOCRACY
SPILL THREATENS THAT RIGHT.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE IMPOSES A
FINE AND THREATENS CRIMINAL
LIABILITY FOR EXERCISING THE
PEOPLE'S RIGHT TO GATHER
SIGNATURES TO QUALIFY AN
INITIATIVE WE THINK THIS GOES
TOO FAR.
WELL THE FINDINGS SUGGEST THAT
THIS BILL IS NECESSARY TO
ADDRESS THE PERCEPTION OF
SIGNATURE GATHERING ISSUES THIS
PERCEPTION IS NOT SUPPORTED BY
THE DATA FROM THE STATE'S
ELECTION FRAUD INVESTIGATION
UNIT.
JUST TASK WITH VIGOROUSLY
PROTECTING INITIATIVE PROCESS.
THE BILL ALSO SUGGESTS THAT THE
SYSTEM CAN BE SKEWED BY WELL
FUNDED INDIVIDUALS OVER THERE
ARE MANY WILL FUND A NOT FOR
PROFIT COMPANIES AS WELL.
PROHIBITING HOW THESE PARTIES
PAY THE PARTIES THEY HIRE TO
DESCRIBE THE ISSUE TO THE PUBLIC.
DOES NOT ADDRESS THIS ISSUE
BECAUSE THERE'S NO COMPELLING
EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT THE PAYING
ON A PERSONAL BASIS SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED A CRIME UNDER THE LAW
CAL CHAMBER RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES
THIS.
I PRINT LAYING A CALIFORNIA
QUEEN MONEY CAMPAIGN I DON'T
ALWAYS HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
WORKING SIDE BY SIDE WITH THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE HONOR.
ON BILLS BUT I THINK THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT.
IS ACROSS THE AISLE THECONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE WE VERY MUCH AGREE
WITH THE THE NEED AND CONCERN TO
LIMIT THE UNDUE INFLUENCE OF
SPECIAL INTEREST IN THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS.
AND WE'VE WORKED ON THE DISCLOSE
ACT ANOTHER THING OTHER BILLS
WITH.
MANY MEMBERS A COMMITTEE HERE TO
DO SO -- HOWEVER WE HAVE TWO
MAJOR CONCERNS WITH THE CURRENT
BILL IN TERMS OF POTENTIALLY
SHUTTING OUT OF THE PROCESS A
PARTICULARLY GRASSROOTS SORTS OF
ORGANIZATIONS GOOD GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHERS THAT.
DON'T HAVE WEALTHY BACKERS -- SO
ONE ONE PROBLEM IS THE 10%
THRESHOLD -- WE AS A COVER
COMMITTEE CAMPAIGN IS A
GRASSROOTS ORGANIZATION ARE VERY --
SYMPATHETIC TO THE IDEA OF
HAVING TO SHOW SOME SORT OF
GRASSROOTS SUPPORT -- FOR TO
QUALIFY AN INITIATIVE THAT THE
PROBLEM IS THAT A 10% THRESHOLD
ESPECIALLY AFTER THE LAST
ELECTION -- THAT HAD SUCH HIGH
TURNOUT COULD BE -- IMPOSSIBLY
HIGH FOR MANY GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATIONS -- TO QUALIFY THAT
ARE THAT ARE REALLY RELIANT ON
VOLUNTEERS FOR CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENT TO BE SET ON THE SAFE
SIDE THAT'S OVER A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND SIGNATURES
YOU'D WANT TO HAVE TO GATHER --
THAT IS.
NOT THAT MANY GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE GOOD
GOVERNMENT ORGANIZATIONS ARE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO TO DO THAT --
WE PUT IN OUR LETTER THAT THAT --
THOSE CAN'T THE CONCERNS WOULD
BE ALLAYED IT WAS A LOWER
THRESHOLD LIKE 5%.
ON THE OTHER PART IN THAT NOT I
DON'T KNOW THERE IS A WAY TO
RELAY THIS IS THE IDEA OF
BANNING SIGNATURES BY BEING PAID.
TING SIGNATURES BASED OFF OF THE
UPPER SIGNATURE BASIS -- IT IT
SOUNDS APPEALING ON THE SURFACE
AND I CAN CERTAINLY SEE --
CONCERNS THAT SOME SIGNATURE
GATHERERS TRYING TO GET AS MANY
SIGNATURES THEY CAN THEY ARE
ALWAYS THEY DON'T ALWAYS --
FOLLOW THE TRUTH IN DOING SO AND
THAT'S WHY WE ARE WORKING ON
SPONSORING SB FORTY SEVEN THE
PETITION DISCLOSE ACT TO MAKE
SURE AT LEAST THEY HAVE TO SHOW
WHO'S WHO'S PAYING FOR THEM.
BUT THE THE FACT OF THE MATTER
IS IT'S GOING TO SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE THE COST.
THE FLORIDA LEGISLATURE JUST A
COUPLE WEEKS AGO.
NOT PASSED THE BILL THAT
TRANSPARENTLY WAS ABOUT LIMITING
THE INITIATIVE PROCESS.
THE SARATOGA'S AT TIMES HEADLINE
ON THAT WAS FLORIDA LAWMAKERS
PLACE BARRIERS TO BALLOT
INITIATIVES THAT WAS THE
HEADLINE OF THAT THERE WAS VERY
TRANSPARENT ABOUT STOPPING.
SLOWING DOWN THE NISHA PROCESS
AND A KEY PART OF THAT BILL THAT
THEY UNFORTUNATELY PASSED IN THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED.
WAS TO BAN PAYMENT OF SIGNATURES
ON A PER SIGNATURE BASIS BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT IT COULD RAISE
COST.
ESTIMATES UP TO TWICE AS HIGH.
NOW IF YOU'RE A A WEALTHY
SPECIAL INTEREST IF YOU'RE A
CORPORATION ORDER ORDERED OR ARE
BIG LABOR UNION OR A A BIG
BILLION HERE.
A COUPLE EXTRA MILLION BUCKS IS
JUST THE COST OF DOING BUSINESS
THEY'RE GONNA PUBLIC SPEND A LOT
MORE ON THAT AND THE SIGNATURE
COUNTY PACE.
BUT IF YOU'RE A GRASSROOTS
ORGANIZATION GOOD GOVERNMENT
GROUPS.
THAT MAY BE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN YOUR INITIATIVE.
BEING ABLE TO QUALIFY AND NOT SO
THAT'S WHY WE ARE STRONGLY
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED THOSE TWO
PIECES THANK YOU -- AROSE WHEN
I'M SORRY GO AHEAD.
A BRIEF.
DURAS LEGAL IN VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE A. B.
FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE AND WE'VE
APPROACH OPPOSE PRIOR SIMILAR
BILLS.
PROHIBITING THE PAYMENT OF
PETITION CIRCULATORS PER
SIGNATURE COULD SUBSTANTIALLY
RAISE COSTS FAVOR WEALTHY
INTERESTS.
I REALLY DRIVE IN EQUITY THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS PAYING HOURLY.
TENDS TO BE VERY EXPENSIVE AND
MUCH LESS EFFICIENT AS AN
ENTERPRISE.
BY CRIMINALIZING CONDUCT THAT'S
ASSOCIATED WITH SPEECH IN WITH
DIRECT DEMOCRACY THIS BILL
TRAVELS A VERY DANGEROUS ROAD
ONE THAT'S DISFAVOR BY THE
COURTS ALREADY.
AND UNNECESSARY WE'RE SIGNATURE
FRAUD DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE
REALLY SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM.
THE IDEA OF 10% OF SIGNATURES
COMING FROM ON PAID CIRCULATORS
FOR MEMBERS OF NON PROFITS WITH
SKIN IN THE GAME.
WHO CARE ABOUT THE ROLE OF AN
ISSUE MAYBE LAUDABLE IN THEORY?
BUT THERE ARE MANY LEGITIMATE
ORGANIZATIONS DOING IMPORTANT
WORK WHICH ARE NOT ORGANIZED
AROUND A LARGE MEMBERSHIP AND
COULDN'T MUSTER THAT LEVEL OF
VOLUNTEER OR STAFF COMMITMENT.
THE UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES OF
THIS BILL COULD SIGNIFICANTLY BE
WORSE THAN THE ABUSES AT THE
BILL AIMS TO PREVENT AND SO WE
ASK.
FOR A NO VOTE ON THIS BILL.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
JACKSON FROM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY OPPOSE.
JOHN KERRY MENLO PARK OPPOSE
ENLISTED MEN AND AMENDED.
JOHN COMISKEY SAN JOSE COMPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED.
JIM DAVIDSON FROM LOS ALTOS WITH
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY OPPOSE A
LESS AMENDED -- LINE -- UP FROM
OAKHURST CALIFORNIA OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED THANK YOU.
TIPPING FROM SAN JOSE CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY AND I POST UNLESS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
FINLEY FROM SAN JOSE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED.
KATHY FORK IS DAVIS CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN I OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED.
LARRY BATHGATE FROM MILL VALLEY
CALIFORNIA NINE OPPOSE IN LESS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING DEBORAH LANGAN FROM
MOUNTAIN VIEW I OPPOSE THE
AMENDMENT AND LESS -- UNLESS.
AMENDED AS STATED.
JAMES PEARSONVILLE RYE
CALIFORNIA AND OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED THAT STATED.
CAROL CROOKS OAKLAND I OPPOSED
INVESTMENT IT IS RECOMMENDED.
JUNIOR LIBEL HELLO TO AYE
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED.
MARIA DEGROOT FROM LONDON
CALIFORNIA OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
SURELY SHOWING US THE PLEASANT
HILL AND I'M OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED.
THOMAS SACRAMENTO AND I AM
OPPOSE UNLESS AMEND IT.
ANNETTE BUT WHEN FROM STOCKTON
CALIFORNIA OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
PAM JOHNSON SAN JOSE OPPOSED IN
LESS AMENDED.
HIS INTERNET STOCKTON OPPOSE
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S CHIRLA
MORAN I'M FROM ALSO I OPPOSE
THIS.
UNLESS AMENDED AS DESCRIBED
THANKS.
CAROL CROSS REDWOOD CITY AYE
OPPOSED SURPLUS AMENDED.
AT L<c.cyan>G LOS ALTOS HILLS OPPOSE</c>
UNLESS AMENDED.
IGGY MILLER OLIVERA -- SAN IS A
OPPOSE UNLESS AMEND.
HIS NAME THEIR CALIFORNIA MANY
CAMPAIGN OPPOSE IN THIS AMENDED.
GREAT CHECK A TEENY CONCORD
CALIFORNIA OPPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED.
JEAN CHECK EIGHTEEN A CUT
CONCORD CALIFORNIA OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED.
DAVID SMITH SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY VOLUNTEER
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
LA COMFORTS OAKLAND CALIFORNIA
OPPOSED TO LESS AMENDED.
THAT SAX SERVICEABLE LIMóN BOND
HIS DISTRICT IN OAKLAND AND I
DEFINITELY OPPOSE THIS.
KAREN SMELLS IN ELSA BRONTE
CALIFORNIA AND DEFINITELY OPPOSE
THIS.
SUSAN SATTAR HOME SAN FRANCISCO
CALIFORNIA A PROPOSED UNLESS
AMENDED.
ECUADOR SACRAMENTO CLEAN MONEY --
VOLUNTEER OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
CHRISTOPHER LESS FROM CENTER
HELL PLEASE OPPOSE ON THE
WESTERN AND KEVIN.
CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA THE
MONEY ACTION FUND PLEASE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED.
NANCY NOW PHONE TWO WITH CLEAN
MONEY PLEASE OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED.
OKAY -- BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS.
YES CENTER LIMóN [inaudible]
HERE -- SO WHAT IS THE AMENDMENT
THAT THE OPPOSITION IS LOOKING.
FOR THE CALIFORNIA MONEY
CAMPAIGN IS LOOKING TO STRIKE
THE BAN ON ON PAYMENT PER
SIGNATURE BECAUSE OF THE EXTRA
COST IT WOULD END UP.
IMPLY -- WE WOULD REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION IF IF THAT WERE TAKEN
AND THE THRESHOLD WERE LOWERED
FROM 10% 25%.
OKAY AND THE LEGAL VOTERS
CALIFORNIA IS A STRAIGHT OPPOSE
NO MATTER WHAT NO MATTER WHAT
OKAY AS HE KILL CHAMBER OKAY I
APPRECIATE THAT -- SO THE PERSON
THE CHORE THE THE BAN ON THE
PERSON YOU TO WHITE WHAT DOES
THAT GIVE YOU HEARTBURN.
A HONG KONG THEY HAVE A GIVES A
HEARTBURN AND I THINK IT.
EVERYBODY ELSE YOU WOULD AGREE
THAT IT WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE THE COST OF SECOND ORG.
SIGNATURE GATHERING ESTIMATES A
A IN IN FLORIDA THERE WERE
PRESENTED WERE UP TO TWICE THE
COST OF SIGNATURE DOWN BECAUSE
YOU KNOW THEY'RE NOT.
AS INCENTIVIZE TO GO OUT THERE
AND FIND THE VERY BEST PLACES AT
CENTER THERE'S LOTS OF REASONS
WHY IN A PAYMENT PER HOUR JUST
DOESN'T HAVE THE SAME.
IMPACT AND AND AGAIN -- WEALTHY
INTERESTS THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY
A PROBLEM BECAUSE I'LL JUST PAY
THE EXTRA TWO MILLION THEIR
PUBLIC WITH A LOT MORE FOR AN
INITIATIVE.
BUT IF IT'S A A GOOD GOVERNMENT
INITIATIVE IF IT'S A GRASS
ANOTHER KIND OF GRASSROOTS
INITIATIVE -- IT'S IT IT COULD
BE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
QUALIFYING AND NOT WHICH IS WHY
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT TO US.
SO I WOULD JUST SAY FROM MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE -- I WAS IN
THE LABOR MOVEMENT FOR TWENTY
YEARS AND WE DID A LOT OF
SIGNATURE GATHERING AND I HAVE
SEEN THE THESE.
THE SYSTEM JUST CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY OVER THE YEARS THE
HIGHER THE PRICE IS ON THE
PERSON MITCHELL -- JUST
ANECDOTALLY WHATEVER I HAVE
FOUND IS THE MORE PEOPLE LIE --
AND YOU CAN ASK MY FAMILY AGAIN
THIS IS ANECDOTAL BUT I AM THAT
PERSON WHEN I'M WALKING INTO A
GROCERY STORE WALKING INTO
TARGET THAT'S GOING TO ASK THE
SIGNATURE GET AND I DON'T SIGN
ANYTHING ANYMORE BECAUSE I DON'T
TRUST MOST OF THEM.
SO MY CONCERN IS IF WE DON'T
CHANGE THE SYSTEM.
WE IT'S JUST GETTING WORSE AND
WORSE YOU KNOW SO MY QUESTION
ALWAYS IS TO THE SIGNATURE
GATHERER.
HOW MUCH YOU BEING PAID DO YOU
ACTUALLY KNOW WHAT YOU'RE ASKING
PEOPLE TO DO 99% OF THE TIME
THEY HAVE NO CLUE WHAT THEY'RE
DOING AND THEY WILL EVEN SAY TO
ME?
YOU KNOW -- I'M JUST TRYING TO
MAKE SOME MONEY HERE LADY COULD
YOU JUST SIGN IT AND I'M LIKE NO
I WANT YOU TO MAKE MONEY BUT SO
I'M WORRIED THAT THE THAT TH
THE WAY WE PUT THINGS ON THE
BALLOT -- AND PROPOSITIONS HAS
REALLY COME BECOME VERY POLLUTED
AND THE THE 10% SIGNATURE
GATHERING.
I MEAN I'M INTERESTED IN THAT
BECAUSE WHEN I WAS WITH THE
LABOR MOVEMENT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE TOYED WITH AND AND HOW
DO WE I UNDERSTAND THAT
VOLUNTEER.
COMMUNITIES ARE VOLUNTEER
ORGANIZATIONS AND NON PROFITS
MIGHT HAVE A LITTLE BIT OF A
HARD TIME WITH THAT.
I GET THAT.
BUT ON THE OTHER SIDE THE
CORPORATIONS OR WHATEVER THEY
HAVE TO FIND VOLUNTEERS AS WELL
AND THEY'RE NOT GOOD AT FINDING
VOLUNTEERS THEY'RE GONNA PAYING
PEOPLE.
SO THEY HAVE TO FIND 10% OF THE
SIGNATURES THE VOLUNTEERS ARE
PEOPLE WHO YOU KNOW COME FROM
THE COMMUNITY OR WHATNOT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THEY KNOW HOW
TO DO THAT THEY KNOW HOW TO
WRITE CHECKS.
SO I I APPRECIATE THE THE
CONCERN BECAUSE I DO THINK THIS
IS THIS IS A HARD SITUATION --
AND I WOULD ASK THE AUTHOR YOU
KNOW IF THERE'S SOME WAY YOU
GUYS CAN WORK OUT ANY.
UNDERSTATES NOT GONNA WORK OUT
ANYTHING WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS WHICH WE LOVE YOU
GUYS THANK YOU FOR WAITING.
WE'VE JUST MIGHT NOT AGREE ON
THIS BUT IF THERE'S SOMETHING
YOU GUYS CAN WORK OUT YOU KNOW I
LIKE TO JOKE AND SAY THAT IF
EVERYBODY WALKS AWAY A LITTLE
HAPPY IN A LITTLE UNHAPPY WE'VE
REACHED A GOOD NEGOTIATION.
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY BECAUSE I DO THINK THE
SYSTEM IS BROKEN AND WE NEED TO
DO SOMETHING TO RAIN SOME OF
THESE THESE CAUGHT.
I AND I WORRY ABOUT THE COST BUT
WE NEED TO RAINY AND WHAT
CORPORATE AMERICA CAN DO AND I
THINK BY HAVING SOME SORT OF
VOLUNTEER PROCESS.
CHANGES THAT -- WHETHER OR NOT
WE CHANGE IT TO FIVE OR 10% --
I'LL LEAVE THAT TO BOTH OF YOU
BUT I THINK THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
OF ISSUE THAT I'D LIKE TO SEE
THE BILL CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR OTHER QUESTIONS.
SO SOME OF OUR LOVE.
AND TO THE OPPONENTS A COUPLE
OTHER QUESTIONS.
I HEARD WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT THE
ESTIMATED INCREASING COSTS AND
ALL OF US ARE PRODUCTS OF OUR
OWN EXPERIENCE.
THE THREE OF US UP HERE OF ALL
RUN FOR ELECTION BEEN INVOLVED
IN ELECTIONS.
I'M IN AND HOW DO YOU ARRIVE AT
THE CONCLUSION VERY IMPAIR DATA
THAT SAYS IF YOU PAY FOLKS BY
THE HOUR IT WILL INCREASE COSTS.
OF TIMES.
TO I'M.
I'M NOT AWARE OF EMPIRICAL DATA
MAYBE.
MAYBE THE THE CHAMBER IS -- BUT
I THINK IT'S IT'S IT'S IT'S
QUITE NATURAL WE WE AT HIGHER
ORGANIZER'S AND AND WHEN YOU YOU
NATURALLY GIVE ORGANIZER'S -- IN
SIGNATURE GATHERERS INCENTIVES
TO GIVE THEM INCENTIVES HEY YOU
GET AN EXTRA TWENTY SIGNATURES
THEN.
WILL YOU'LL GET A FREE THEY WILL
GIVE YOU A FREE TRIP TO
STARBUCKS RIGHT DID JUST THAT
SORT OF INCENTIVE MAKES A A BIG
DIFFERENCE -- SO IT -- WE'VE
TALKED -- TO OTHER FOLKS HAVE
BEEN ENGAGED IN SIGNATURE
GATHERING PROCESS.
THAT'S AREN'T ALWAYS AT HIGHS
DOUBLE IT COULD BE I'VE HEARD
ESTIMATES AS LOW AS 20% OF AN
INCREASE BUT EVEN A 20% INCREASE
ON A PROCESS THAT MAY COST TWO
THREE FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
ALREADY.
IF AGAIN IT'S NOT A PROBLEM FOR
THE WEALTHY -- INITIATIVE.
FUNDERS THEY CAN JUST PAY THAT
EXTRA COST I MEAN IT IS A LITTLE
BIT OF A IT'S DEFINITELY PROBLEM
BUT THEY'LL STILL BE ABLE TO
QUALIFY THEIR INITIATIVES WHAT'S
GONNA HAVE THE PROBLEMS.
EVEN AN EXTRA 20% THAT MEANS AN
EXTRA FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
EXTRA MILLION DOLLARS IT HAS TO
BE PAID. FOR A GRASSROOTS
INITIATIVE FOR A GOOD GOVERNMENT
INITIATIVE WHICH TYPICALLY IS
NOT BACKED BY WEALTHY FUNDERS.
THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT.
PROBLEM TO INITIAL PROCESS
BECAUSE IT'S MEANT TO IS MEANT
TO ALLOW GRASSROOTS THE VOTERS
TO BE ABLE TO QUALIFY.
AS AN OPTION.
ANY I MEAN I THINK THAT LORNE
EXAM WILL BE THE BEST EXAMPLE OF
EMPIRICAL DATA TO DATE AND THAT
DOES SUGGEST THAT THERE'S
ADDITIONAL SIGNIFICANT COST ME
THE ISSUE FOR BUSINESSES
OBVIOUSLY IS OUR EMPLOYEES ARE
VERY ENGAGED AND INTERESTED IN
THESE TYPES OF ISSUES.
BUT THEY DON'T NECESSARILY
ALWAYS HAVE TIME WE DON'T HAVE A
LARGE VOLUNTEER BASE TO MOBILIZE
WHEN THESE ISSUES COME UP
THROUGH TALKING ABOUT PAYING
THEM. TO DO THEIR WORK AND THEN
PAYING THEM AFTER THE FACT ON A
TO GIVE THEM AN INCENTIVE TO GO
DOOR TO DOOR AND BE MORE
EFFICIENT WITH THEIR TIMES
THAT'S WHERE THE COST INCREASES
COMMON.
IN MENTION FLOWS THEIR DATA FROM
FLORIDA THAT INDICATES THAT THE
COSTS OR IS IT BETTER THEIR
ESTIMATE I BELIEVE THERE IS AND
I'M HAPPY TO LOOK INTO THAT
PROVIDES YOU AFTER THE FACT THAT
WOULD BE USEFUL -- OKAY IN IN IS
AN EARLY VOTE ILLUSTRATES IS
THAT WE ARE ALL PRODUCT OF OUR
OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AND
SINCE ALL OF US UP HERE HAVE
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE IN ELECTIONS
[inaudible]
HISTORICALLY.
FOLKS WOULD DO VOTER
REGISTRATION BY SIGNATURE BY
VOTER REGISTRATION CARD.
AND THEN AT LEAST -- I THINK ON
THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE ALLEGED IT'S
GONE THE HOURLY. TO INCREASE
BASICALLY THE QUALITY -- AND SO
OUR OWN EXPERIENCE LEASE MY OWN
EXPERIENCES WHAT YOU'RE DOING IS
YOU'RE INCREASING THE QUALITY OF
THE REGISTRATION -- UP I'LL PUT
THAT OUT THERE AND OTHERS CAN
DISAGREE IN THE SECOND.
OBSERVATION IS IN THIS IS
OBSERVATION FROM ELECTION --
ABOUT ONE YEAR AGO IT -- I I
OBSERVE FOLKS REPRESENTING THE
RECALL PETITION WAS A REPEAL OF
THE GAS TAX AND THE AT THE END
THAT.
WAS IT WAS CLEARLY A FALSEHOOD
AND I THINK.
PEOPLE ARE INCENTIVIZED TO TO
LIMIT THE GAS TAX SIGN THE
PETITION THINKING THEY WERE.
SIGNED A PETITION DILEMMA THE
GAS TAX AS OPPOSED TO RECALL SO
I THOSE THOSE THOSE EXPERIENCES --
INFLUENCE MY JUDGMENT HAVING
SAID THAT THOUGH IS THAT I AFTER
MEETING WITH FOLKS I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT THE 10%
THRESHOLD I AM INTERESTED IN.
REDUCING IT 25% I REALIZE THAT
WE CAN'T DO THAT TODAY BUT I'D
ASK THE AUTHOR WILL WELL IF THEY
WOULD CONSIDER IF HE WOULD
CONSIDER.
REDUCING IT FROM 10% 25%.
SURE I'M AT MY CLOTHES OR WHAT.
WE WILL HAVE OTHER QUESTIONS BUT
RIGHT.
YOU CAN YOU CAN ADDRESS IN YOUR
CLOTHES YOUR LIFE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SENATORS VERGE OF QUESTION.
YEAH I MEAN I'M LOOKING AT THE
ANALYSIS AND IT GOES BACK TO THE
MISS CENTER LENO'S BILL IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX AND THEN.
COURT SENATOR CORBETTS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINE IN THE BILL IN
200-011-2000.
SIXTEEN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
YEAH AND THIS INDIVIDUAL CAN GO
BACK TO FOR A LONG TIME BEFORE
THAT WE'VE SEEN THESE THINGS
INCLUDING A COMMISSION THAT I
DID IN A PREVIOUS LIFE.
ON INITIATIVE REFORM AND TRYING
TO LOOK AT THIS TOGETHER WITH A
NOT FOR PROFIT GROUPS THAT WE
SPEND MILLIONS AND MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND CORPS INCLUDED --
JUDGES FORMER CHIEF JUSTICE IN
OTHER ASSOCIATE JUSTICES SUPREME
COURT AS PART OF THIS ENDEAVOR.
TRYING.
TO YOU KNOW.
THE THE THE THE PUBLIC LOVES THE
INITIATIVE IT IS EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPORTANT TOOL WE GET THAT AND
THAT IS IMPORTANT CHECK ON
GOVERNMENT IN MANY WAYS.
CERTAINLY I CENTER LABOR JUST
TOLD ME I HAD THE SAME
EXPERIENCE WITH MY IN REFERENDUM
ON MY SB TEN ON BAIL WERE THE
PEOPLE JUST SAY WHATEVER THEY'RE
GOING TO SAY IN ORDER TO GET
YOUR SIGNATURE IRRESPECTIVE OF
THE TRUTH.
THERE INCENTIVIZE OF COURSE BY
ON HOW THE PAY STRUCTURE WORKS
AND WE ALSO KNOW FROM THOSE OF
US WHO'VE BEEN EXPERIENCE THAT
THESE FOLKS THAT DO THIS STUFF
TRAVEL FROM ALL AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
AND THEY JUST BUILT UP THE
NUMBER AND WITH THE HIGHEST
NUMBER IS IRRESPECTIVE OF THE
ISSUE DOESN'T MATTER.
THEY MAKE DECENT MONEY IN THERE
THEY KIND OF THAT'S WHAT THEY DO
AND SO WE HAVE BEEN GRAPPLING
WITH THIS FOR DECADES FIGURING
OUT HOW DO YOU BALANCE OUT ON
THE ONE HAND.
THE THE UNDERLYING NATURE OF
THIS PROCESS WHICH IS.
CRITICALLY APPROPRIATE IMPORTANT
WITH WHAT'S TRANSPIRED BECAUSE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT JUST I
APOLOGIZE IF IS ALREADY SAID I'M
SORRY JUST VOTING IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE.
BUT WHAT HIRAM JOHNSON CAME UP
WITH THIS THIS RUBBER FORM ALL
IT WAS ALL ABOUT GETTING RID OF
POWER IN SACRAMENTO WHEN IN FACT
NOW WHAT'S HAPPENED IS IS OF
FOLKS THAT HAVE MONEY.
THEY'RE ABLE TO ACTUALLY
OVERTURN THE POWER THE COMMUNITY
THE LAST TIME I REMEMBER THAT
WAS ALMOST A COMPLETE -- CITIZEN
DRIVEN -- VOLUNTEER DRIVEN
ENDEAVOR WAS NINETEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT WITH PROP THIRTEEN I DON'T
REMEMBER ANYTHING SINCE THEN.
THAT HAS BEEN REALLY DRIVEN BY
FOLKS VERSES INTEREST GROUPS ON
WHATEVER SIDE OF THE THE TRADE
THERE IS.
WE'VE LOOKED AT THIS IS 5% AS
THE CHAIRMAN HAS SAID.
IN THE PAST FOR COSTS OF THE
REASONS YOU KNOW IT'S ONE OF
THESE FIGHTS THAT WE KEEP
ENGAGING IN AND SOME YOU KNOW
TOOK FORTY FIVE TIMES FOR THE
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT PASSED THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS SO.
I THINK THE THE FACT THAT
IMPORTANT PUBLIC POLICY ISSUES
TAKE A LONG TIME ISN'T THE
DECEIT REASON WHY YOU DON'T KEEP
UP THE FIGHT.
BUT I WOULD SUGGEST THAT FOR THE
REASONS IF HE HAS NOT
ARTICULATED THAT WERE TO GO TO
IN YOUR ANALYSIS.
THAT 5% AS WE HAVE DONE WITH THE
NEWMAN BILLS IT WITH LENO AND
WITH CORBETT AND EVERYBODY ELSE.
PROBABLY MEETS THE NECESSARY
THRESHOLD -- IN TERMS OF
CREATING A BIG ENOUGH OF AN
ORGANIZATION.
THE LAST POINT I WANT TO MAKE IS
ONE OF THE ODDITIES IN THE
CIRCUMSTANCES JUST FOR HE
RECORD IS.
THE DETERMINATION OF HOW MANY
VOTES ON THE SIGNATURE G. IS
DETERMINED BY PREVIOUS
SELECTIONS IF YOU HAD A REAL
HIGH TURNOUT ELECTION ALL OF A
SUDDEN YOU HAVE A REPORT AN IDEA
YOU WANT TO PUT THE BALLOT.
IT'S INFORMED BY A MUCH HIGHER
THRESHOLD IN A LOW TURNOUT
ELECTION KIND OF A LITTLE BIT
IRRATIONAL BUT THE TO THE EXTENT
THAT AT LEAST A 5% NUMBER YOU
CAN GET IT SEEMS TO ME THAT YOU
HAVE SUPPORTED THIS OVER AND
OVER AGAIN OVER THE YEARS.
BUT THAT WOULD BE HELPFUL AND I
JUST AGAIN I YOU WANNA MAKE ANY
COMMENTS ON YOUR CLOTHES WOULD
BE GREAT I JUST WANTED TO ADD
THAT IN FOR THE RECORD.
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN GRAPPLING
THIS WAS SUCH A LONG TIME TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO CREATE A A
APPROPRIATE INTEGRITY.
IN A PROCESS THAT IS INFORMED BY
THE PUBLIC ON THE ONE HAND.
AND AND IT REALLY IT HERE'S TO
THE UNDERLYING ARCHITECTURE AND
POLITICAL PHILOSOPHY THAT IS SO
IMPORTANT OF THE REFORM MOVEMENT
OF A HUNDRED YEARS AGO.
THE OTHER QUESTIONS OF OUR YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
COMMENTS AND THE ROBUST DIALOGUE
ON OUR DEMOCRACY AND CENTER
HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE
ALSO THAT YOU PROVIDED.
WITH RESPECT TO THESE ISSUES AT
HAND -- ANECDOTALLY.
MY EXPERIENCE WAS REAFFIRMED --
WITH RESPECT TO THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION I JUST COME BACK
FROM THE GYM WEARING A BASEBALL
CAP GOING OUTSIDE TRADER JOE'S.
AND INDIVIDUAL APPROACHED ME AND
SAID DO YOU WISH TO STOP THE
TYRANNY OF THE SACRAMENTO
POLITICIANS I SAID PLEASE DO
INFORM ME ABOUT WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT.
AND THEY HAD SAID DO YOU WANT TO
REPEAL THE GAS TAX AND I SAID
WILL PLEASE EXPLAIN TO ME WHAT
THIS IS ME SAID WELL YOU KNOW
THE POLITICIANS ARE GOING TO BE
USING THESE REVENUES THE BALANCE
THE BOOKS SOMEWHERE ELSE.
I SAID I THINK THEY'RE FACTUALLY
INCORRECT AND HE SAID WHAT WOULD
YOU KNOW.
AND I SAID OKAY WELL LET'S HAVE
A CONVERSATION ABOUT THAT.
BUT AS WE BEGAN TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION HE THEN SAW.
AN ELDERLY WOMAN APPROACH HE
MERELY STOPPED MID SENTENCE
TRYING TO EXPLAIN OR TO HAVE
THIS DIALOGUE.
AND WINTER HER.
AND I SAID EXCUSE ME I I'VE I%
WANT TO BE INFORMED ON THIS AND
HE SAID -- EXCUSE ME I'M GOING
TO SOMEONE TO TRY TO COLLECT A
SIGNATURE.
AND I STOPPED AND SAID OKAY I'M
JUST GOING TO STAND AND OBSERVE
ANY REPEATED HIMSELF AND THE
WOMAN SIGNED THE THE BALLOT --
THE THE THE PETITION.
AND I STOOD THERE AND SAW HIM DO
THIS DO THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
THERE WAS NO THERE WAS AN
INCENTIVE TO GET THAT SIGNATURE
NOT TO HAVE A FACTUAL
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT.
AND SO WHEN YOU INCENTIVIZE THAT
INDIVIDUAL FROM CHASE OF THE
SIGNATURE THERE IS NO.
TYPE OF INTEGRITY IN TRYING TO
HAVING A ROBUST DIALOGUE WITH A
FELLOW CALIFORNIAN AND A FELLOW
VOTER ABOUT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
FUNDAMENTALLY.
IS DOING WHICH IS TO SAY THAT WE
MUST HAVE TRANSPARENCY THIS BILL
PROVIDES THAT YOU MUST HAVE
DISCLOSURE OR WHATNOT YOUR
VOLUNTEER OR PAID SIGNATURE
GATHERER.
WE WANT TO STILL ALLOW FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO BE ABLE TO
SOLICIT SIGNATURES BUT YOU'RE
PAID BY THE HOUR BUT NOT BY THE
SIGNATURE TO NOT INCENTIVIZE
THAT TYPE OF BEHAVIOR.
AND IN ADDITION AS YOU'VE OF
PREVIOUSLY STATED -- WE CONTINUE
TO LOOK AT OPPORTUNITIES TO
MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY OF A LOT
THE TOTAL PROCESS.
I'M I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO
COMMIT TO HAVING FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH RESPECT TO
THE PERCENTAGE OF THE
QUALIFICATIONS YEAH SHOULD THIS
MOVE FORWARD INTO THE FUTURE --
BUT AGAIN I THINK THIS IS
FUNDAMENTALLY ATTEMPTS.
TO FOCUS ON THAT OF THE
INITIATIVE PROCESS AND WHAT.
FINISH THE PROCESS ABOUT.
DEMOCRACY IN THE GRASS WAS
PROCESS BUT YOU ALSO HEARD FROM
CENTER HERTZBERG AS TO WHEN THE
LAST TIME AN ACTUAL PEER
GRASSROOTS INITIATIVE MEASURE
ACTUALLY OCCURRED I THINK THE
AVERAGE INDIVIDUAL HAVE SEEN.
THAT SAID WHY THE LEGISLATURE
WHY NOT DOING OUR JOBS WHY DO WE
MAKING THESE DECISIONS ON THESE
TEN PROPOSITIONS WHEN NO MEANS
YES INVESTMENTS KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
DOING YOUR JOB.
AND WATER HERE'S OF FALSEHOODS
THAT CONTINUE TO BE EXACERBATED
IN THIS PROCESS AND AS SOMEONE
WHO FORMALLY TAUGHT POLITICAL
SCIENCE AT THE END THE COMMITTEE
BECAUSE WHEN I TALK TO STUDENTS
ABOUT THIS THEY SAID WHAT WHY IS
IT SO OMPLICATED.
AND WHY WE TELLING THE TRUTH
THIS IS ABOUT TRANSPARENCY IN
TELLING THE TRUTH AND WE SHOULD
BE GETTING MONEY OUT OF THIS
INITIATIVE PROCESS. TO TAKE AWAY
FROM THAT OF WHAT WE ARE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH IN CHIEF AND
YOU'VE HEARD FROM THE FELLOW
COMMITTEE MEMBER AS TO WHEN THE
LAST TIME SUCH A MEASURE.
QUALIFY TO AGAIN -- I JUST --
AND IN THIS POSITION TO CARRY
THE WATER IT FROM PREVIOUS
MEMBERS OF THIS LEGISLATURE AND
HELPING TO ACCOMMODATE THIS
ISSUE AT HAND WHICH IS TO
MAINTAIN THE INTEGRITY OF OUR
ELECTORAL PROCESS AGAIN.
I AM COMMITTED TO LOOKING AT THE
A PERCENTAGE AS IT MOVES FORWARD --
SHOULD THIS NEW FORD AT THIS
COMMITTEE THANK YOU.
SO THANK YOU I THINK YOU'VE
HEARD AT LEAST TWO OF US SAY
THAT THAT WE'RE INTERESTED IN
CHANGING THE 10% 25% SO I AM
HOPING YOU'LL KEEP US.
INFORMED AS TO THE PROGRESS IN
NEGOTIATIONS AND I KNOW THIS IS
GOING TO I THINK IT'S PUBLIC
SAFETY FROM HERE -- SHOULD IT
SHOULD MOVE OUT OF THE COMMITTEE --
SECOND POINT IS YOU LETTER
SAYING DID YOU SIGN THE PETITION
THE THE INDIVIDUAL THE NINETEEN
OPPORTUNITY TO STOP THE TYRANNY
OF THE SACRAMENTO POLITICIANS
CORRECT I DISPUTE INSIDE ARE AND
I WOULD I KNOW -- ALL RIGHT.
NO THE QUESTIONS -- IS THERE A
MOTION.
SO MOVED BY SENATOR HERTZBERG
ALL RIGHT MA'AM SECRETARY MOTION
IS TO PASS THE SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE NUMBER.
NUMBER GUY NIELSEN.
NIELSEN NO HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE LEYVA LEYVA AYE
STERN.
STERN HI.
THE BILL IS OUT -- IT TO PUBLIC
SAFETY OKAY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE REMEMBER LAW ALL RIGHT -- WE
HAVE SOME SEVERAL BILLS ON CALL
IF WE WOULD LIVE CALLS.
ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B. FIVE
BEFORE BERMAN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE EYES NO NOSE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG ICE STERN -- STERN HI
[inaudible] FIVE ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT.
THE GOVERNOR ITEM THREE AB SIX
NINETY THREE BERMAN.
MOTION IS TO PASS CURRENT VOTE
IS TO AYE AYES AND ONE NO WITH
THE CHAIR.
CURRENT VOTE IS THREE GUYS AND
ONE KNOW WHAT THE CHAIR VOTING
AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE.
THAT.
ON THE CONSENT ITEM WE HAVE AB
TEN FORTY THREE IRWIN.
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE.
ITEM SIX FOURTEENTH.
WE DID.
ITEM SEVEN AB SEVENTEEN OH SEVEN
BERMAN.
MOTION IS TO PASS CURRENT VOTE
TO EYES ONE KNOW WHAT THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE STERN STERN.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU -- WE'RE
JOURNEY UNTIL JULY